Gloria needs watching she's got a
serious case of pregnancy brain last
week I found a bar of soap in the fridge
and a stick of butter in the shower I
walked around all day smelling like a
bucket of popcorn
better than the toast I ate
yeah you ate the second piece
seriously I'm right here
I didn't really call you did I no my dad
did but I thought you knew I want to be
so mad at him but he's right I have two
brains in my body but I've never been so
dumb it happens I get it you have
another human being inside of you
competing for resources look when I was
pregnant with Alex I could barely
remember my name same with alien look
hmm so much they kind of just hang out
in there let me do my thing
thank you for understanding I'm glad
that you came
it will help me not to forget stuff I'm
glad I can help out whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa why didn't you stop fast
okay hey where did you go to get a
sweatshirt we've been standing in the
frozen food aisle for half an hour I
need something Frozen right what I don't
know I just wrote the word Frozen Okay
uh let's think peas ice cream pizza
waffle wait a minute
it says Dawson's I need the eggs ah the
eggs okay I know on the other side
oh I've got I've got the cart so that's
oh sorry that's that's me that's me I
got it so Alex comes home from school
the other day and she says the teacher
didn't know what she was talking about
in reality I don't think that whoa whoa
whoa
whoa I forgot the eggs excuse me yeah
yeah hang on one second listen this is
not just your pregnancy you are
purposely turning your brain off you
have to at least try to pay attention
ma'am yeah do you have a receipt for
that sweatshirt oh shoot oh I'm gonna
need you to come back into the store oh
no no it's I forgot I was wearing it
it's no big deal here ma'am the store
are you kidding me I didn't try to steal
a sweatshirt sir I'm a mom Gloria help
me out listen Mr policeman if we wanted
to steal it you wouldn't even know that
it was gone yeah okay that's not helping
why would I buy hundreds of dollars
worth of merchandise and then steal a 20
sweatshirt I don't know
maybe you do it for the thrill
I know you type your board housewife
drives a minivan husband spends a little
too much time online got a couple of
kids a college degree you don't use you
could not be more wrong yes she has
three kids okay no no no no no no no
that's not helping
look as I said before it was an accident
I heard it
a thou grandmother's
they all say the same thing it was an
accident I don't know how that clock
radio got my pants oh for God's sake I
don't feel well let us go you're right
is that even a baby
come here
I need you to sign this admitting your
guilt and promising you'll never return
to the store no I'm not signing that
okay great then I'm gonna call the
police and I'll be forced
what was that
I'm having
her hang in there hang in there I'll get
you to the hospital as soon as I can I
just want to apologize One More Time On
behalf of the store for any stress that
I might have caused you here you can
keep the sweatshirt as a gift and
congratulations on this baby which is
clearly not a turkey that was go away
now yeah all right go on go on
what hospital are we going to no no
hospital wow oh you're one of those oh
okay please don't have it in the pool
though because we swim in there I'm not
having the baby Claire I was just Faking
It
not bad for someone with pregnancy brain
huh okay that's good that was very good
good thinking Gloria I'm sorry I just
couldn't sit there and watch you
suffered just because you had turned
your brain off okay I deserve that
oh no oh no no no no I just blew through
a red light damn
I think he keeps the pregnancy thing up
for a little while longer
[Music]
thank you
foreign